Hi guys! Tyler and I were sent out this past week
to visit Axel for the Make-a-Wish foundation,
uh it was a last minute trip, but we were happy to go
uh and when we got there we got to meet, Axel his whole family and the hospital staff
every one in his support  group and it was a really cool time because there was food, video games
and we just spent all day, pretty much spent just playing Rocket League and Skylanders
and he kicked our butts at Rocket league
real bad, either that or we're just playing bad at it
but it was a lot of fun and then Axel towards the end of the day
had something that he wanted to tell you guys
and I promised him I would put it into the video
so here's that message
So, we're here with Axel and Axel wanted to say something to you guys
Uh, You have any prepared statements, a speech of some sort?
No I just - thanks for always supporting Markiplier,
'cause I can't, I can't subscribe to him
since I don't have my own YouTube/Google account.
But if I did, I would, I would comment on every single of his videos,
and subscribe and like all his videos,
so thank you so much for, for helping Mark even though I can't.
Aww (background giggles)
That's really sweet, thank you so much
It was really interesting to hear that and it's not what I expected him to say
because I've never heard it from that perspective before
where someone is an avid fan and yet they weren't able to support what I do
And I was just honoured, you know,
I was kinda humbled, because I get so much support and
it was a reminder that
I'm literally not here or I wouldn't be here
if it weren't for you guys and
I wouldn't be able where I am today
and I wouldn't be able to do what I wanna do
and I wouldn't be able to do these charity efforts
and  I wouldn't be able to go out and visit people for their wishes,
if it weren't for you guys.
I just wanna thank you everyone for being there for me
and supporting what I do and
supporting what we do here
and just making it something
really, really special.
So anyway, I just wanna make this short and sweet
this video is mostly about Axel's message
so I'll leave it at that.
Just thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see you in the next video
Buh-Bye!